this is a kind of catch-all chapter
chapter 29 what's going on in this
chapter they're bringing together couple
different groups that are not actually
they're not directly connected with each
other what we would say genetically like
one of them springing off of the other
they're coming out of a common problem
at the common cultural situation and
they all represent new religious
movements that become new denominations
new churches so they've started talking
first about sort of big picture themes
with this and they say two themes but
specially dominated the quest for the
meaning of America well limitless space
and new beginnings in time you have to
do a bit of imaginary work in order to
make this click for you because I don't
think that these are themes that we
currently feel our central in our lives
how many do you feel like you could like
pick up any time and just go somewhere
else start over new those opportunities
don't really exist like they used to do
they why not I mean you guys are all in
school right now but let's say let's say
you got your degree in hand can you just
go anywhere you want right as they say
write your tickets there's no frontier
for you to go out to is there get your
40 acres by cultivating it what's the
job market like right now for you guys
yeah it's a good way to describe it
probably use all sorts of swear words
for it is it likely to get better by the
time that you graduate do you feel like
you have a lot of opportunities to just
pick up and completely start over again
it could be that this part of the
American experience is something that's
harder for you guys to relate to the
harder for me to relate to as well that
it was for earlier Americans so you have
to do a little bit of imagining a little
bit of sort of you know putting yourself
out of the front here where there were a
lot of more opportunities where you
could actually start over again you know
the new beginning in time you want to
put yourself in that mindset they talk
they talk about certain times and places
as being especially susceptible to the
rise of cultural trends and new
religious movements so they use the
example of California which you might
not associate with religion at this time
but there's a lot of new movements as we
go further the book they're going to
come out of California including one of
the pre actions of pentecostalism the
New England area we've already seen a
number of different things coming out of
there to other places that they talk
about in this time period that are
really important our Kentucky and New
York in New York they talk about the
burned-over district why is it called
the burned-over district because there
were so many revivals that you know
everyone's lighting a new fire pretty
soon that entire Upstate region has been
metaphoric or burned over by all these
new new ways of looking at things yeah
and some of the other groups that we're
going to look at are going to come out
of there Kentucky why does Kentucky
important you don't really associate
Kentucky with new ideas in terms of you
know religion and culture these days
it's seen as a conservative area isn't
it but at the time that was the frontier
and all these people were pouring
through the Cumberland Gap in the
mountains into this broad area getting
away from the city
getting away from previous ways of doing
things and there were a lot of revivals
taking place in Kentucky your book talks
about the one of the great revivals was
the key and ridge revival in Bourbon
County Kentucky Bourbon County is you
know or long bourbon comes from so you
never go on the Bourbon trail that's
that's one of the places to go to but at
that time what we're looking at is
revivals and religion and this guy Stone
Barton Barton Warren stove he's
associated with what we're going to call
the Christian restorations and this is
another up early mid 1800s don't mix
this up by the way the Christian
reconstructionist movement which is a
much later movement that takes place
which is associated far right these guys
are coming together from a couple
different places you have this guy
Barton Stone who starts out being a
Presbyterian and then gets kicked out
why does he get kicked out well because
he's too revivalists he's too much into
this emotional type of spirituality I
made the Presbyterians back east say
were not for that and so they have to
split ways along with this goes another
guy thomas campbell and he's coming
originally out of Northern Ireland
Ulster emigrants of Pennsylvania gets in
trouble with his co-religionists there
and forms a new group called the
Christian Association and they're doing
things very similar to just own and then
we have another guy Walter Scott and do
you join us forces with with this guy
Alexander
Alexander Campbell in a bit and all
these groups are doing the same sort of
thing they all have the same basic
emphasis back to original Christianity
they wanted to end the divisions because
think about this if you were a Christian
at the time and we're talking about the
next thing that somebody would ask you
is well what kind of Christian are you
Baptist are you Methodist with an
Anglican this capelean are unitary any
your Congregationalist and you know
certain point you want to say look I'm
just a Christian those are just
denominations those are just sort of
external forms why are we so divided why
are you know if we're all supposed to be
Christians Christians are actually
supposed to be in unity isn't that a
sign that somebody's getting it right
that they can all be on the same page
the original Christian Church wasn't a
whole bunch of different churches of
Baptists and Presbyterians and
Lutheran's was it if you read the book
of Acts does it mention any of those
groups not really so they want to get
back to you original Christianity what's
the blueprint for that done how would
you do that if you if that was your goal
right now he said we're going to begin
new wipe the slate clean gotta get away
from all these these churches by now
there's actually over 10,000 different
denominations if you want to get really
technical about it be in the United
States Christian denominations that's an
awful lot look at so let's say you say
wipe all this stuff away we're going to
begin again what do you begin with one
very good
okay so ever the bible is the sole
source have we heard this before yeah
very very beginnings of the Protestant
Reformation is sola scriptura the Bible
alone so what we're seeing is sort of
like a new reformation of the
Reformation occurring this is a theme
that we see over and over again in
American history the new beginnings are
such low beginnings right one James
streets mind if I get words wrong let me
know do you see it up there okay the new
beginnings aren't always so new
oftentimes they're repetition of some
other previous theme and that's what's
happening with this like a book says one
of the key models is where the
Scriptures speak we speak with the
scriptures of silent were silent and
their view was you can find everything
that you need in the Bible they were not
particularly liked your book points out
emotional they're not like the Great
Awakening churches like Baptist churches
or Methodist churches they're much more
rationalistic in town their view is that
well if you just you know apply yourself
to studying the Bible you'll figure out
what Christian life ought to look like
what Christian community ought to look
like and you can thereby follow what the
Scriptures teach you and improve the
world they're post-millennial in that
that that sense and they give rise to
one big church movement the restoration
asst take all themselves by a couple
different names this is one of the early
one disciples of christ here's another
one churches christ and then some of
that will just call themselves
christians i will say where the
Christian Church and
these two terms disciples of price and
churches of christ end up becoming the
names for some of the denominations that
arise from them it's kind of a hiring
right because these guys are all about
overcoming denominations after a while
they end up splitting you know it's very
hard to get everybody to agree
completely about the Bible of what it
teaches as we saw earlier with the
Protestant Reformation right different
different groups go different ways
disciples of Christ are the more urban
centered one there one of the large
churches here in the United States today
the two different groups that go by the
term of Churches of Christ large
presence in Indiana but not a large
presence nationwide they're sort of
shrinking a bit and some of them are so
conservative as to not even allow organs
in the church because you find any
organs in the Bible nope so shouldn't
have those that's where this this group
comes from the restoration is the
disciples of Christ really undone more
or less fitting into the Protestant
mainstream and that's that's their
origin now another one of the the key
developments that's going to take place
is what we call millennium
I don't know if it's spelled right but I
don't know if any of you don't rip the
smell great either and this is a
premillennialism sometimes this gets
called Adventism so premillennialism as
opposed to post millennialism which
we've already talked about
premillennialism is view that the second
coming of Christ is going to happen
prior to the Millennium prior to the
thousand years where everything is great
so usually associated with this tends to
be things like the notion of the rapture
that people are going to get drawn up
into heaven which is very hard coming
from Paul's leverage to the
Thessalonians sort of interesting
quarter not not a particularly old
doctrine by the way it's it's a fairly
recent this notion of the rapture some
people think that there's going to be a
lot of you know they call trials and
tribulations before that like it all
sorts of things going going down the
world wars cataclysms others like like
William Miller thought that it was going
to happen really soon so their belief
was the second coming of Jesus is going
to come prior to the millennium and
William Miller looking about the 1840s
here William Miller starts making
predictions and he is looking at the
apocalyptic books books of the Bible so
that would be like you know Book of
Revelations Book of Daniel there's other
pakka lip tick literature as well
actually a lot of the apocalyptic
literature didn't make it into the final
cut
the Bible which is interesting to to see
there's a whole story there but when
people start reading these books in
particular it's not like reading the
Gospels and looking at the Sermon on the
Mount trying to figure out well how
angry can i get with my brother you know
Christians are different about that it's
more like well what is the Beast
represent or what are the seven seals or
what is this supposed to be and they
people start making all sorts of
correlations and predictions with this
apocalyptic literature and they're
they're notoriously difficult to
understand and interpret but people make
a shot at a well then another figured
he'd keep cracked the code and he
started making predictions about when
the coming of Jesus Christ is going to
happen and you know for the Christians
and if you actually do know the time
when price is supposed to show up then
you should really just focus on that and
a lot of these people sold their homes
sold their farms sold all their
implements sold your extra clothes gave
all that stuff away gave it to the poor
because they thought that it was going
to happen and your book mentions a few
dates March 1843 October 1844 was what
they call the great disappointment most
of his followers left after that after
that point and it was actually a not a
public health but what he called it sir
like a public ordered problem because so
many people in some of these areas had
sold off all of their goods and you
couldn't recover them now most of the
Adventists end up leaving here's where
the story gets even more interesting is
Laney LNG wife she has what she
describes his visions she also writes a
lot of books you can actually find her
books pretty easily and used bookstores
because they've been printed in millions
of copies and she wrote like you know
anywhere from estimates Mary somewhere
around like 30 to 40 books these are
thick books she was a follower of Miller
yeah she married a minister and writer
she said that she had visions over her
lifetime and and your book talks a
little bit about the origin of this I'm
going to actually skip over that because
that's getting into a little bit of like
religious psychology and what happens is
that white attracts a lot of followers
white attracts she's got charisma she
begins to teach she adds a number of new
emphasis and refinements you know if
you're having visions you can say well I
had a vision about this we had a vision
about that and what we get coming out of
her stuff and the people around her is
what we call the Seventh day Adventists
they are one of the main groups of
Adventist that that's why they actually
are a big church here in the United
States they had they operate by the way
the third largest school system
religious school system in the United
States just behind the Catholics and
Lutheran's they are they run a lot of
hospitals they for a group that believes
it's sort of a running joke in religious
studies for a group that believes that
the end is near they certainly do spend
a lot of time on infrastructure I'm
building things that you're going to
need if the end isn't near right now
yeah they focused a lot on on some other
things that had a wall not just an
American religion but in American
culture in general how many ate
breakfast today that few it's kind of
unfortunate some of you look like you're
a bit confused how many of you have
breakfast cereal only one or two how
many to eat breakfast cereal you know
what I came from original the entrances
how long the guy who got you know how
long he started was the seventh day
adventist and the adventist focus very
much on bodily period they felt that
eating a diet full of meat wasn't good
for you they also if I should drink and
you know smoking and things like that as
well breakfast cereal get started as as
a way to have healthy grains nuts you
know fruit that that sort of thing like
your book points out you know L&G way
probably would not be for cocoa puffs or
lucky charms or things like that I
particularly like blueberry cuz ya
little marshmallows and it turns of milk
blue and stuff like that but she
wouldn't be for that because it's full
of sugar and marshmallows that's not
good free well I think about you know
the corn flakes or total raisin bran all
those are so special k right special
case must be very healthy all those are
coming out of this way of life that the
Adventists are are living your book also
talks very quickly about these utopian
communities close with the term down
here most of these are very short lived
the two exceptions would be the Anaya
community and the shakers both of which
have very interesting orientations
towards sexuality the shakers have died
out if in large part because they viewed
sexuality is fundamentally bad and
sinful and so they live together in
basically monastic communities men and
women they are very egalitarian when it
came to what it came to respect to
relations between men and women but
there was there was supposed to be no
sex they were called shakers because
they they would engage in this dance
that talks about ecstatic dance with him
they would actually shape during the
dance they die die but their furniture
still remains and if you get your hands
on it's quite good the entire community
was a little bit different it was
started by this guy to claim that he and
he was sinless and anybody else could be
sinless and it was sort of a commune
they they actually had to move one time
because of their practice of complex
marriage how much comforts marriage
means that such what that marriage is
complicated by itself which it is but a
lot of dinner partners they would
connect up in sort of plan ways
particularly through this is carefully
regulated reproduction that they called
stir pop culture and so that didn't dear
them to some of the locals and they had
to move eventually they settled down and
in a night up and they survived for a
couple generations but then they die the
utopian communities don't tend to last a
very long time in the United States and
the utopians are kind of connected with
this whole broad theme your book is
weaving together three different stories
here the restoration of the Adventist
and these utopian communities they're
all three very different ways of living
out starting a new direction in in a
Christian life in America and they're
all indigenous Lee American they all
begin here as opposed to Lutheran's who
came over from Germany Catholics who
came over from all over the place
Presbyterians that came over from from
Scotland these are new American
religions so that's where we'll leave
one